all right welcome everybody so the
midterm has just been uploaded online so
you can download it I have it right here
I wrote it a little bit over the weekend
and I solved it yesterday it took me
about 45 minutes to solve this so so I
think four hours is pretty fair it's not
the easiest exam but it's also not the
hardest exam okay so on a graduate exam
I'm trying to prepare you for the
qualifying exams and you know to be able
to use these ideas in your own research
and so not all of the problems are
exactly like what we've done in
homeworks so far but almost everything
has been done in the lectures okay so
for example I thought it would be fair
to give you a little bit of a heads up
on some of the things that I'm going to
ask on the midterm that I may not have
actually had a homework on so for
example I'm going to have you do a very
very simple convolution integral okay
I'm going to do one in class for the
first five minutes just to kind of work
through it I also expect you to know how
to solve for OD ease that have external
forcing so for example using the method
of undetermined coefficients that we did
I think two lectures ago okay so if I
have some you know X double dot plus x
equals e to the minus 5t you should be
able to solve the homogeneous unforced
equation and the particular solution
with that forcing and you should be able
to figure out what all the coefficients
are with initial conditions okay you
should be able to do all of the exam
based on what we've done in the class I
will have a question on phase portraits
so if I were you before taking the exam
I would just make sure that I really
understood the examples on face
portraits like the particle the bead on
a wire things like that okay any
questions about the exam yeah
so you are allowed to use MATLAB on some
of the problems and it's explicitly
stated where you can I think the only
thing you'll need MATLAB for is to like
check your answers so a lot of times
you'll do something by hand but you can
check that your math is correct by you
know for example plotting your solution
with the MATLAB solution and that that's
totally ok so it's a four-hour take-home
exam you don't have to do it all in one
sitting you can you know do some here
and some there and you can use any of
the online PDF notes or your own course
notes or the online videos or your
solutions to the homeworks
but nothing else no internet no friends
no books no yeah nothing else ok that's
it for the exam it's uploaded now let's
do it 5:00 p.m. on Wednesday ok so I'm
going to do a really really really quick
convolution integral example just so
that we're all on the same page because
I didn't actually do any problems on
convolution yet so let's say I have an
equation X dot equals minus 2x plus e to
the T and I have some initial condition
X naught equals 5 ok so what are the the
parts of solving this with a convolution
integral so you solve the homogenous
part first you say ok well X of T is
equal to e to the 80 in this case that's
just e to the minus 2t times X naught
times 5 plus the integral from 0 to T of
e to the minus 2t minus tau times
whatever my forcing term is as a
function of tau this is really important
so e to the tau D tau I have two
variables here T and tau I'm integrating
with respect to tau and I want a
function of T at the end ok
so this e to the minus 2t minus tau is
really two Exponential's e to the minus
2t times e
the plus 2 towel and since I'm
integrating with respect to Tao I can
pull the T term out of the integral so 5
e to the minus 2t plus e to the minus 2t
times an integral from 0 to T of either
the 2 tau e to the Tao detail please
stop me if there's anything wrong or if
there's any questions ok this is e to
the 3 towel so so what's the integral of
e to the 3 towel with respect to tau ok
it's 1/3 e to the 3 towel and the bounds
of our integration are from 0 to T so we
have to evaluate this at T and then
minus this evaluated at 0 right this is
just how we do a definite integral ok so
that equals the homogeneous term 5 e to
the minus 2t plus e to the minus 2t and
now I'm going to evaluate I'm going to
plug in T here so I get 1/3 each of the
3 t minus if I plug in 0 I just get 1/3
ok we're almost there
now we just kind of collect like terms
ok so I'm first want things that have a
each of the minus 2t so I have 5 e to
the minus 2t minus 1/3 e to the minus 2t
so that equals 5 minus 1/3 e to the
minus 2t and then the only term left
over is this term which is 1/3 e to the
T
and that's the answer and you can check
first of all that if you plug in this
particular solution then X dot equals -2
X plus et is true for for 1/3 e to the T
and you can also check that X has the
right initial condition so if I plug 0
in for here I get 5 minus 1/3 times 1
plus 1/3 times 1 so it really is my
initial condition X naught equals 5 ok
so we should know how to do convolution
now I'm probably not going to give you
anything terribly difficult like I'm not
going to give you a matrix formulation
but I want you to know the mechanics of
how to do convolution it's super
important ok any questions yeah here and
the final answer so we're multiplying
everything in here by e to the minus 2t
so we pick up a minus 1/3 e to the minus
2t and then we have a plus 1/3 each of
the positive 1/2 okay so that should be
about 10 points on the midterm all right
now I want to start on an entirely new
topic today ok so up until now we've
been doing analytic solutions of OD es
we're really just doing foundational
theory of linear systems of equations
and you know linear and non-linear OD es
for the next i think two weeks we're
going to be talking about numerical
solutions to calculus ok numerical
differentiation numerical integration
and numerical integration of OD es ok so
most of the techniques I showed you only
apply to a very small class of ordinary
differential equations that are linear
but almost all of the problems that
we're actually going to be interested in
are really nonlinear and so we need
computers to help us solve them ok so
starting today for about two weeks we're
going to dive into computational
differential equations in calculus ok ok
we're going to start with numerical
differ
shishun okay so I think on the first or
second day of class we wrote down the
formula for the derivative and all of
numerical differentiation and numerical
integration is based on kind of basic
definitions from calculus and the Taylor
series okay so let's just start from
scratch so given a function and I want
to make this point that we're not just
doing numerical calculus on functions
we're not just integrating numerical
differential equations that are defined
by functions we can also do everything
we're talking about on data okay so
let's say you go to work for Amazon and
you get a big data set from your boss
the same methods that we can use to take
the derivative of a function numerically
we can use to take the derivative of a
data set numerically so if you get
position data for a satellite you can
compute its velocity and acceleration
for that satellite okay so this is kind
of one of my favorite things I love data
science and we're going to be building
in kind of a data science module into
both 5/64 and me5 65 next quarter right
so I want you all to be data literate
and proficient with actually working
with real data because more and more we
can't even write down equations for the
things we're trying to solve but we do
have more and more data okay so given a
function or data f of T so some function
of time or some data that's just you
know sampled in time we have this
definition of a derivative so we have
some function f in time and looks like
this so the definition of the derivative
is DF DT is equal to the limit as delta
T goes to 0
f F T plus Delta t minus f of T divided
by delta T here this is just the
definition of calculus definition of
derivative from calculus that we're all
familiar with so let's just draw a
picture of this so if I have some point
T where I want to compute the derivative
of my function I just take my function
at T and I take a point T plus delta T
and I look for the slope of the line
connecting these and that's as delta t
gets smaller and smaller and smaller and
this right blue point gets closer and
closer and closer then this red line
becomes ever closer to the tangent line
of the function at that point T and the
slope of this line is the derivative
okay so this is this is just our
definition of derivative from calculus
now for a lot of our careers we've been
really taking this limit seriously and
actually taking it to zero computing the
derivative but it turns out that for
computers this is a much more useful
formula if we just say that we're going
to have some finite delta T and that
this expression is approximately equal
to our derivative right in a computer I
can never take the real limit as delta T
goes to zero I'm always dealing with
finite precision numbers I can't take
arbitrarily small numbers and so we're
going to be approximating derivatives
using real finite differences with real
points that are separated delta T in
time okay so this is what we're going to
be doing all of this week for a
numerical differentiation and numerical
integration is looking at expressions
like this okay any questions so far
yeah so since we're dealing with
should be expect to be examined on those
in the phones as well I probably won't
do any machine learning in the
qualifying exams because I don't think
that's fair to people to haven't taken
my version of the class I will be
teaching dimensionality reduction and
some basic machine learning in the
second half of the class because it's
stuff that everyone should know so in
the past before computers every graduate
student in mechanical engineering needed
to know Oh des and linear algebra and
Laplace transforms and complex analysis
and now I think every graduate student
in mechanical engineering needs to know
how to do numerical calculus and basic
dimensionality reduction and data so I
will be incorporating those they
probably won't have either much or any
influence on the qualifying exam at
least until a couple of years from now
when almost everyone's taken my class
I'm also shamelessly promoting for the
data science program so there's a new
East science major at the University
with four classes around like data
management data visualization machine
learning and statistics which if you're
interested in in data science I'm an
affiliate of that program and you know
it's a great great program with great
classes okay so let's let's start
thinking about this a little bit more so
we have this expression that our
derivative with of our function with
respect to time or our data with respect
to time is this approximate expression
in terms of f of T plus delta T and F of
T but I don't know how good is this
approximation so how what are some ways
that I could kind of analyze how good
this approximation is I'm sorry yeah so
how do I assess like this is really plus
some error exactly so what is this error
okay I could pick a point and really
compute the derivative and then compute
this and I could take the difference and
that would be the error that's exactly
right but what I want is I want to know
beforehand if I might not know the true
derivative so I want to be able to bound
what the error is kind of from first
principle so what we're going to do is
we're going to compute the Taylor series
of both of these expressions and we're
going to look at terms in the Taylor
series and see you kind of if that gives
us some some insight okay so first I'm
going to look at F of T plus delta-t
and we're going to Taylor series we're
going to write the Taylor series about
the base point T expand it in the
variable delta T okay remember we've
done this before so maybe you all can
just help me write this down this is f
of T plus plus F prime yet DF DT
evaluated at T times what times delta T
plus 1/2 d squared F DT squared or the
second derivative times delta T squared
good plus 1 over 3 factorial d cubed F
DT to the third of T times delta T to
the third and I hope I don't need to
keep writing any more terms but I might
okay good I'm going to write down one
more because this is going to be useful
in a minute
so what about F of t minus delta T how
would I write this down what's the
easiest way to write this down like I
literally just plug in delta T negative
delta T every time I see a delta T here
so all of the even terms stay positive
and all the odd terms pick up a negative
so this is f of t minus DF DT plus 1/2
because this is an even term it has a
so T squared minus one over three
factorial
third derivative plus dot dot minus F
dot so on okay okay so now what we want
to do is estimate what the error looks
like for this approximation to the first
derivative okay
we're calling this a forward difference
a forward difference approximation
because if I want the derivative at a
time T I look one delta T in the future
forward and I use that to compute this
so this is called a forward difference
okay and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this first Taylor series
expansion and plug it in for F of T plus
delta-t
okay so forward difference is f prime
approximately equal to F of T plus Delta
t minus F of T divided by delta T okay
so what is this expression f of T plus
Delta t minus f of T
I literally just take this Taylor series
and I might I subtract f of T and so I'm
left with everything with a power delta
T or higher okay so this is equal to 1
over delta T times all of this stuff
past f of T so it's equal to 1 over
delta T DF DT times delta T plus d
squared F DT squared delta T squared
plus dot dot dot forever okay any
questions up to this point there is a
1/2 good thank you seem to be terrible
keeping track of my very important
factorial decay on my Taylor series
okay so we're really really close now
okay I'm going to divide everything in
here by a delta T and we're going to get
that this equals DF DT evaluated at my
point T these D T's cancel plus 1/2 d
squared F DT squared times a single
delta T because one of them cancelled
plus more stuff dot dot right there's
going to be a delta T squared a cubed
1/4 and forever right this this is a
whole Taylor series so there's more
stuff but what we have here is a really
really useful expression okay this
approximation is equal to the first
derivative of f with respect to time
which is what we want all right this is
what we want all along ok and everything
else is error
we want this to be as close to df/dt as
possible
but this expression equals df/dt plus a
bunch of other terms from the Taylor
expansion okay so there's more and more
and more error terms because this
expression isn't exactly equal to the
first derivative
okay we're using finite size Delta T's
is everyone with me so far
yep and so what we say is that we're
going to take delta T small right we're
going to make delta T as small as we can
reasonably make it in a computer and so
the delta T term is going to be much
bigger than the delta T squared term and
that's going to be much bigger than the
delta T cubed term and so what we say is
that this term is the dominant error
term so if we make delta T small this is
going to be the biggest error term and
all of the other error terms are kind of
negligible compared to this pretty
massive error and we say that this is on
the order of delta T so if you give me a
delta T of 0.01 then I'm going to tell
you that your error and your
approximation is going to be on the
order of 0.01 it's going to be some
number times 0.01
if you cut your DT in half your error is
going to cut in half if you divide your
DT if you make your DT 10 times smaller
your error gets 10 times smaller because
it's order delta T the leading error
term is of the size delta T okay
questions about this before we move on
because this is kind of the core
principle for everything we're going to
do for the next two weeks
any questions at all yeah just assumed
that we review our units fidelity are
such that these lessons that's a that's
a good point okay so so the question of
units is this is definitely not a dumb
question this is one of the best
questions you can ask at this point are
how do the units affect everything this
is actually kind of a subtle point and
it's very very very important so I could
measure time in milliseconds or I could
measure time in decades and we know that
that shouldn't actually change anything
as long as I do it consistently in all
of my measurements and then all of my
quantities right it doesn't matter what
I call it I still I'm going to have the
same derivative of F with respect to
time so if this delta T is measured in
milliseconds instead of decades what
else about this equation changes
the units of my derivatives also change
okay so as this gets larger this term
will have to get smaller because it's
being divided by a DT squared so that's
kind of the way that this is unit
invariant is that if I change units on
this number then this thing also changes
units and becomes much much smaller but
as a general rule you're right
we need delta t to be small in the sense
that if i have this function f delta t
has to be small compared to kind of the
big curvature features of this function
right so the second derivative of F is a
measure of curvature and I want my DT to
be small enough that I'm not kind of
jumping across a big hump in my function
because that would be a terribly
inaccurate derivative so I need to be
kind of small compared to these big
curvature features or this needs to be
small compared to this term this is kind
of hand wavy we're going to get more
examples we're going to do this in a
computer and really see you know what
changes when we make delta T bigger but
that's actually a great question this
idea that the dominant error term is on
the order of delta T though is still
important if you cut delta T in half
your error should go down about by a
factor of a half okay okay good so what
can we write here so now this is exactly
equal to this expression exactly equal
to this plus order delta T okay that's
exactly true for the forward difference
but there's lots of other ways of
computing derivatives so what's an
alternative approximation to my first
derivative instead of just doing a
forward difference right I could do a
backwards difference I could take I
could take a little point at t minus
delta T and I could approximate it using
the
slope between that line right I could do
it backwards difference approximation so
I could say DF DT equals f of T minus f
of t minus delta T divided by delta T
and if I plug in this Taylor series
expansion for that new backwards
difference expression my ex cancel I'm
again left with the first derivative
plus something that's order delta T so
this has exactly the same error
properties and this is called backward
difference okay what if I wanted better
error properties is that this actually
is not very good this means that if I
want a thousand times less error I have
to sample a thousand times more finally
that's not good so what would be how can
I use those Taylor series expansions
those F of T plus Delta T's and those F
of T minus Delta T's to get a better
approximation to the derivative with a
higher-order error term okay so I can
use something called central difference
or Center difference that's not how you
spell central so we have DF DT equals so
here we're going to have F of T plus
Delta t minus f of t minus delta T
divided by 2 delta T and we're going to
work this out but we're going to see
that this has order delta T squared
which is better we'll figure out why
this is better in a minute so the best
thing we can possibly do is actually use
one point forward of T you know this T
plus delta T and one point behind T and
approximate the slope of the line
between those two points okay so that's
more accurate way of computing the first
derivative so let's see why
so you can kind of see why this is just
from from looking at these two things
okay what we really want is DF DT and we
want as few of these higher-order terms
as possible because these are
contributing to my error so I want to
cancel these two if possible and be left
this left like this
third order term so the way I do that is
just subtract these two terms okay
so f of T plus Delta t minus f of t
minus delta T is equal to okay all of
the even terms cancel because they have
the same sign all of them F of t minus f
of T is zero one half second derivative
times delta T squared minus the same
thing as zero all of the even terms
cancel and all of the odd terms have
opposite signs and so I just pick up two
of them so this equals to DF DT delta T
plus 2 over 3 factorial d cubed F DT
cubed delta T to the 3rd power plus what
what is the if I was going to just lump
all of the higher-order terms into one
term but what I call it order delta T to
the what fourth fifth right because all
of the even terms including the fourth
get cancelled okay this isn't magic I'm
just subtracting this one from this one
trying to see what terms cancel see if
it can be useful this is really useful
it's almost what I want so I have to
divide this by 2 delta T and then I get
the thing I want plus some error okay so
F of T plus Delta
G minus F of t minus delta T divided by
2 delta T is equal to the thing I want
which is the first derivative plus all
of these extra terms which I'm calling
error so plus okay I divided by 2 and I
divided by delta T so I get plus 1 over
3 factorial d cubed F DT cubed times
delta T squared plus dot dot ok I'm just
going to write this exactly the same way
as we did before so this is good
this is F prime and this is all error
but now notice that this error term is
proportional to delta T squared so what
are the ramifications here let's say
that you have let's say I email you data
and I ask you to compute the derivative
of the data and it looks really noisy
and crummy and so we both look at the
data and we say okay we need this error
to be about a hundred times smaller how
much do you need to make delta T smaller
to make your error 100 times smaller ten
times okay so before we needed to make
our delta T a hundred times smaller to
get 100 times less error but now we only
have to make delta T ten times smaller
so this is much better right if you make
10 if you make delta T 10 times smaller
that's ten times more data you have to
collect okay so this is really really
good that our error is of order delta T
squared because it means that we can get
less error more easily by making delta T
smaller this is called the scaling this
is how the error scales with the time
step delta-t and this is a better
scaling than order delta T because if I
want smaller error I need to reduce
delta T less here
okay and that's exactly what we have
written here okay so plus order delta T
squared and this is this is better okay
any questions about this delta T order
delta T notation or the scaling or the
error this is important stuff this is
the kind of thing that definitely would
be on qualifying exams this is not like
new enough not to put it on any
questions at all this make sense okay so
do we feel like we could actually code
this up in MATLAB right this isn't too
bad if I have data like let's say I have
data F at a few discrete points that are
separated by delta T and time again this
one but anyway these are you know spaced
delta T apart in time so T 0 T 1 T 2 dot
F 0 F 1 F 2 F 3 dot dot right so I can
stack these into a big F vector and a
big T vector and I can approximate the
derivative of F with respect to T using
the formula we just derived
okay any of these formulas so we're
going to do this in a few minutes let's
think so forward difference in backwards
difference or okay they have order delta
T but central difference is much better
because it has error that is on the
order of delta T squared so when would I
not be able to use a central different
scheme why wouldn't I just always use
central difference why would I even
waste your time with these forward and
backward difference schemes I'm sorry
time series data so what do you what do
you mean by that one page in it you
don't have address so I might not have f
of T plus delta-t if I keep getting data
streaming it so the way I like to think
of this as an asteroid or a missile was
coming at us
take your pick so let's say that this
asteroid is coming towards us and we
have measurements of the position you
know in the past and now and now and now
and we're continually getting updates of
f of T but we don't have F of T plus
delta-t
so we need to use the information we've
had from the past to get a good
approximation so we have to use
backwards difference for that asteroid
data okay how would I make backwards
difference more accurate how could I
make this backwards difference more
accurate yeah yeah so instead of just
having f of t minus f of t minus delta t
i can also have a t minus two delta t
and t minus three delta t at t minus
four delta T I could have a longer
expression and I can take all of those
Taylor series and kind of recombine them
so that I cancel as many terms in the
Taylor series as possible so there are
eighth order backward different schemes
and if you're tracking a missile you
know headed at the u.s. you use the best
eighth order backwards different scheme
you can if you trust your measurements F
what if your measurements ever bad what
do you do then
so every measurement we take every data
point in our function and every number
represented in your computer has some
finite small error associated with it
okay so probably in the next lecture in
the first part of next lecture we're
going to look at how small you can how
accurate can you possibly make this
expression by decreasing delta T so if
you want to make this expression more
accurate you make delta T smaller but at
some point if you make delta T small
enough you're amplifying the errors and
your measurements so there's a tipping
point where you there's a minimum error
you can get four backwards difference
given a numerical error in your
measurement so we'll talk about that on
what's today on Wednesday yeah okay
we're about to go into MATLAB but I want
to do one more example
okay what about the second derivative
what if I want F double prime of T
equals what so how do I take this and
this and maybe F of T and get an
expression for the second derivative of
F okay so I have I this is the thing I
want right this is what we want so what
do I do to these two expressions to
isolate this okay I'm going to add them
so I'm going to say first of all that's
f of T plus delta T plus F of t minus
delta T good so now I have you know one
of those times delta T squared and
fortunately all of my odd terms have
cancelled that's good but I'm left with
two F of T so I have to subtract you F
of T and then I just divide by delta T
squared everyone see what I did here now
I'm trying to isolate this term this is
what I want and so I'm essentially
thinking of these Taylor series as
building blocks and I can do whatever I
want with them to try to get this term
plus as high of an order error term as
possible so first thing I do is I just
add this equation in this equation and I
get exactly my second derivative times
delta T squared but I have extra terms I
don't want I have a plus two F of T plus
something delta T to the fourth so so I
subtract two F of T and I'm left with
let's see d squared F DT squared I
divided by delta T squared so now this
term is that doesn't have a delta T and
I had a plus delta T to the four
term that was kept and so when I divide
by delta T squared I have plus order
delta T squared okay this is a little
too fast to follow every detail I'm kind
of rushing here a little bit so what you
can do is you can actually plug in these
three expressions and you'll find that
every odd term canceled so the first
derivative third fifth seventh ninth
derivatives all cancel the two F of T
also cancels these and I'm left with the
derivative I want plus error that's on
the order of delta T squared so this is
kind of like the central difference
scheme for the second derivative right
cuz I need forward and backward
measurements and you can try different
combinations you can write down the
Taylor series for F of T plus 2 delta T
and F of T minus 2 delta T and you can
come up with a second derivative that's
order Delta t to the fourth it's not
that fun
I wouldn't recommend spending too much
time but it you can definitely play
around up some of these things ok ok so
next time we're going to talk about what
happens when there are errors in each of
these measurements when our data is
imperfect but for now why don't we do a
quick MATLAB demo and just see what
these derivatives look like and how well
they perform
okay
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to cook up a function f where we
know the derivative and then we're going
to see how all these schemes do in
predicting that derivative okay
so I'm going to clear everything I'm
going to make a DT of let's make our DT
equal to point one something small I'm
going to say T equals -2 in increments
of DT - 4 and F is sine of T so let's
just plot T by F that's a test
finite difference okay this is the
function that we're going to be taking
the derivative of we know the derivative
of sine is cosine so we know the truth
okay so let's just say the exact
derivative is D F DT equals coasts of T
this is a vector right DF DT is now a
vector of the derivative at each of
these points in time ok so let's just do
all this plotting here so I'm going to
plot T by F as a black dashed line with
line with one point two good and I'm
going to hold on I'm going to put a grid
on and I'm going to plot T by DF DT in
black with line width three I'm going to
put a legend that says my function is
the black dashed line and my exact
derivative is the derivative is the
solid black line okay good so this
dashed line is the function that I'm
going to take the derivative of this
solid black line is the exact derivative
and now we're going to start computing
approximations and plotting them on top
of this okay
okay so our forward different scheme
okay so how do I do this so for the
forward different scheme it's just sine
of T plus Delta t minus sine of T
divided by delta T so DF DT forward
difference equals just forward this
equals sine of T plus Delta t minus sine
of T divided by DT notice here I'm
actually assuming that I have the
function sine I'm not just doing this
derivative on my vector of data I'm
assuming I actually have access to this
function f soon we'll do this just
assuming we have a vector of data okay
let's do backward difference DF DT
backwards equals sine of T minus sine of
t minus DT divided by t t DF DT central
difference okay so what's my central
difference sine of T plus BT minus sine
of T minus DT divided by 2 DT and now
we're going to plot T by DF DT forward
and blue okay we're going to do the
backwards difference in green and we'll
do the central difference in red so
notice I'm commenting my codes so that I
remember what I do later and then I'm
just going to have a new legend
okay so forward backward central
something bad happens
okay good so remember the black curve is
the thing we're taking the derivative
the black dash is the thing we're taking
the derivative of solid black is the
exact derivative and then these colors
are my approximations
okay so forward and backwards difference
we think should be less accurate right
because they're order delta T and
central difference should be the most
accurate because it's order delta T
squared so let's kind of zoom in here a
little bit and we see that that's
exactly what happens okay so the forward
difference kind of overshoots positive
derivatives and undershoots negative
derivatives that's just based on the
geometry of what we're doing here we
over predict some derivatives and we
under predict other derivatives
backwards difference is the same but
opposite and central difference kind of
is almost perfectly agreeing with the
true solution for positive and negative
derivatives okay so the central
difference is doing what we want it's
acting better than forward or backward
so what's going to happen if I decrease
my delta T from point one to point O one
they should all do better right but the
central difference should do better
faster and so now they're all much much
closer right they're almost all
perfectly on top of this because I made
my delta T smaller the error of the
central difference is actually almost
zero now it's like really really small
error okay what if I make my error my DT
bigger well so my let's see
okay so now all of my error are bigger
but 0.2 squared is still a really small
number it's still 0.04 and so my central
difference only has about 4 percent
error whereas the other ones have on the
order of you know 20 more error a lot
more error okay questions about this
MATLAB code okay so next time we're
going to look at how to do this when we
don't have the true function sign but we
just have a vector of data like your
boss emails you have a vector of data
and we'll start thinking about what
happens when we add error to these
measurements okay thank you